So right here I have
two potential solvents
that you might see some type
of reaction take place in.
The one on the right is a
very typical one, probably
the most common of all solvents.
This is water.
And this right over
here is diethyl ether.
And we'll talk
about naming things
like this in the
future dates, but you
can see what's going
on right over here.
You have two ethyl
groups attached
to this oxygen
between diethyl ether.
But the important point
here is to realize
where are these two
solvents similar?
Where are these two
molecules similar
and where are they different?
The places that they are
similar is in both cases oxygen,
which is one of the most
electronegative of all
of the atoms, that
in both cases,
it's bonded to things that
are less electronegative.
And so that allows oxygen to
hog the electrons more often.
It has a higher
electron affinity.
And so you'll have a
partial negative charge
for both of these molecules
on the oxygen side.
And you'd have a
partial positive side
from the thing that's
getting to spend
less time with the electrons.
So both of these we could
call them polar solvents.
And a general idea
throughout chemistry
is that polar solvents are
better at dissolving ions.
Because a polar
solvent you have kind
of positive negative charges,
things are flipping around,
they're partially attracted
to the other positive ends
of the other molecule.
You could imagine that
it's very easy for an ion,
for something that is positively
or negatively charged here,
to kind of get mixed
in to the fray.
Now the difference
between these two
is obviously what the
oxygen is attached to.
Here the oxygen is
attached to some carbons.
Here it is attached
to hydrogens.
And oxygen is far
more electronegative
than the hydrogens are.
It's a much bigger
differential than the case
between oxygen and carbon.
So in this situation
you will see scenarios
where it is possible
where in a mixture--
remember these things
get really, really messy.
There's a lot of just
random bumping that's
going on over here-- that oxygen
is so electronegative that it
can often times take
this pair that's
in this bond right over there.
And if it did that you would be
left with the oxygen now having
a negative charge.
Before this-- let's
see if I can draw
all of its valence electrons.
It was one, two,
three, four, five, six.
So now it's going to
have one, two, three,
four-- actually maybe I can
draw them a little bit more
carefully.
So you still have, you could say
half of this bond to hydrogen.
Now you have these two pairs.
So one, two, three, four.
And now it gains another pair.
It got both of these electrons.
It was already kind of
sharing half of this bond
but now it has the whole bond.
It has a negative charge.
And then you have the hydrogen.
Well if you strip
it of its electron,
hydrogen is just a
proton floating around.
So let me draw that.
So this hydrogen is now just
a proton floating around.
So when you have water,
water is actually
called a protic solvent.
And then maybe
another water molecule
might pick this up
and take it someplace
forming a hydronium cation.
But this right over
here, water is protic.
Which means that you might have
these protons floating around,
these hydrogen protons.
While diethyl ether
is not protic.
Even in the case that
somehow one of the bonds--
you don't just have
little hydrogen protons
floating around in this.
And so what I want
to now think about,
now that we know about polar
solvents, why they're polar.
But we also know examples of
protic and nonprotic solvents.
Let's think about
which might be better
when we're talking about
the types of reactions
we're studying.
So right over here you
might recognize-- in fact,
it's a good exercise.
Pause this video and
tell me these top three
steps, what type of
reaction is this,
and these bottom two what
type of reaction is this.
Well, in this top one we see
that this leaving group leaves
first, and that this is
the rate determining step.
And then a nucleophile
comes in here
and attacks the
carbocation and attaches.
So this is a
substitution reaction,
but the rate that with a
nucleophile, but the rate
determining step involves
only one of the reactants.
The leaving group's
got to leave.
So this right over here is an
SN1 reaction, only involving
one of the reactants.
The leaving group leaving is
the rate determining step.
This, on the other hand,
both the nucleophile attacks
and the leaving group
leaves in one step.
So this is a substitution
involving a nucleophile,
but both reactants are involved
in the rate determining step.
Now since both SN1
and SN2 reactions
need these ions
floating around you
can imagine that they both
benefit from polar solvents.
So polar solvents
are good for both.
Now let's think
about whether it's
good to have protic or
nonprotic environments
for either one of
these reactions.
Well to think about
that a little bit more
let's think about the
types of nucleophiles
and the types of molecules
we're dealing with.
SN2 reactions, in order
for this to happen you
have to have a reasonably
strong nucleophile.
And the SN1 reaction,
well you already
have the carbocation
set up here,
the leaving group leaving
was actually the hard part.
So this could even work
with a weak nucleophile.
The real thing you have to do
is to get this leaving group
to leave.
And also if we want
to remind ourselves
of some of the other kind
of the stereochemistry
of the reactions,
in an SN1 reaction,
it's actually nice to
have a tertiary carbon.
If these are also carbons, these
little circles I drew here,
that helps stabilize
the carbocation.
So if this was a tertiary
carbon this would favor SN1.
We also know that tertiary
carbon would not be good.
If this is a tertiary carbon
that would not be good for SN2.
Because if these were
carbon chains of some
form-- these three,
this purple, this blue,
and this orange
thing-- then they
would have steric hindrance.
The nucleophile would
have trouble getting in.
So this would be
more likely to happen
if you're dealing with a methyl
carbon or a primary carbon,
maybe a secondary carbon.
So here the nucleophile
is reasonably strong.
Here it can even work
with a weak nucleophile.
Polar solvent in either case.
And the SN1 the key is
stabilizing the leaving group,
making it OK for the
leaving group to leave.
So what's going to help
a leaving group to leave?
Especially when a
leaving group leaves
it typically has
a negative charge.
Well if there were a bunch
of protons flying around that
could help stabilize
this negative charge,
that would help.
In fact, this could then form a
bond with one of those protons.
It could donate electrons
to one of those protons.
And so a protic environment
is good for the SN1.
While on the SN2 since you
have these strong nucleophiles,
if you had protons flying
around, instead of trying
to attack the substrate
right over here,
the nucleophile would
attack the protons.
So you don't want that, then
this thing won't happen.
So you want nonprotic
for the SN2.
So hopefully that
gives a little bit
of the basics of the
solvents and also
allows us to compare these two
reactions in interesting ways.